on pourrait penser que saint benoît sur
loire est un village comme les autres eh
bien non c'est un tort car la commune de
2000 habitants abrite un patrimoine pour
le moins intéressants à commencer par
son abbaye qui a été l'un des premiers
monuments de france
être classé au 19e siècle non là on est
sur le parvis de l'abbatiale
comme vous pouvez constater vous avez
devant vous la tour porsche qui est un
des éléments les plus anciens de la de
l'abbatiale
qui remonte au 10ème siècle ces mille
quatre cents ans d'histoire
en fait pour arriver aujourd'hui 1400
ans d'évolution des bénédictins et de
saint benoît et de l' architecture
romane que représente le l'abbatiale
l'abbaye de fleury mais également une
maison du treizième siècle et des bords
de loire classée à l'unesco
cette richesse patrimoniale plus des
aménagements en centre ville comme ce
cheminement piéton entre l'office de
tourisme et l'abbaye ont permis à la
commune de devenir une petite cité de
caractère
l'association à l'origine de ce réseau
est né au milieu des années 70 et pour
les communes comme ça benoît c'est un
plus pour le tourisme
on attend une des retombées bien sûr
économique mais c'est de se faire
connaître aussi c'est un bon moyen de se
faire connaître au niveau national au
niveau régional bien sûr et donc attirer
un maximum de tourisme de touristes
c'est un peu ce qu'on en attend et en
plus c'est un élément stimulant pour
pour développer la commune
et voir ce que l'on peut faire comment
on peut améliorer les choses dans le
loiret seul ferrières en gâtinais fait
également partie de ce réseau une
dizaine de communes le son en région
centre val de loire